hello my name is Jay labov
I'm currently retired for the last
couple of years for my position at the
national academies of Sciences
engineering and Medicine in Washington
DC where I was senior advisor for
education and communication and my role
was to direct studies of the academies
to help produce reports and to work with
other organizations to try to coordinate
efforts to improve the teaching of stem
which is science technology engineering
and Mathematics I first became
interested in biology when I was about
13 years old when somebody gave me a
present for my birthday which was a book
about ocean exploration by a very
important Explorer at the time by the
name of Jacques Cousteau many people may
not know who he is at this point but his
adventures and the kinds of things that
that he was able to tell us and to
communicate to people who didn't have a
scientific background was so interesting
to me that I decided that I really
needed to think about biology more then
in high school I took another course
with a biology teacher who I found so
interesting
that I said this is my path this is what
I really love I love to learn about
living things and how things work and
how life works and trying to understand
what it is so I enrolled as a biology
major when I was in college this was the
University of Miami in Florida which
allowed us to get out into the
Everglades to go to many places to
really learn how life works not just in
a test tube but in the real world
from there I went to graduate school
finally got in I was rejected from some
of the best places in the country but I
was finally admitted to the University
of Rhode Island and I went there
thinking that I wanted to be a marine
biologist and once I got there found out
the person I wanted to work with who was
working with humpback whales wasn't
taking any students
so I found a place in the department of
zoology and began doing work with mice
and some of the physiology and behavior
of reproduction that led to my Master's
Degree and then to my PhD in those areas
from there I was
interviewed at Colby College and they
invited me to become an assistant
professor there I thought I would stay
maybe for two or three years and ended
up 18 years later progressing through
the ranks until I found this other
opportunity at the National Academy of
Sciences it began to shift my interests
from biological research and just
teaching strictly biology to more of the
educational and policy aspects of of
Science and I think that's one of the
important messages for students to
understand that under being Adept in
biology and in other areas of science
will allow you to go into many many
different kinds of things you don't need
to have necessarily a linear path to
Academia and what I realize is that
teaching is my passion and even now that
I've been retired I've been going to try
to give back by going and volunteering
in a local elementary school
uh to work with teachers and students to
help them understand you know how how
wonderful and important science is
because it's really important for people
of all ages to understand these kinds of
Concepts